abbassa la testa
se la donna della mia vita
non sei abbastanza
hai un talento straordinario
fi marcire tutti i rapporti che hai
attorno
non capiranno non sono la tua altezza
ma perché te la prendi tanto me l'hai
detto tu di renderti migliore di come
sei
quanto pesano queste parole
c'è chi le sa le ha vissute sulla
propria pelle
io le ho subite
tecnicamente si chiamano montagne russe
emotive un giorno se non essere speciale
e il giorno dopo non merita di esistere
la violenza psicologica
camminare è netta non lascia tracce non
lascia lividi e subdola
eppure il peso di queste parole segnale
spalle molto più di uno zaino dapprima
tdc non ti preoccupare andrà sempre
meglio
man mano che camminerà in questo peso
diventerà sempre più leggero
no no e le vittime di violenza lo sanno
molto bene
questo peso schiacciata domina come una
malattia che non ha una durata
eppure una cura church
oggi vi racconterò una storia
oggi vi racconterò la mia di storia e di
come camminare aree curarla
il primo persone già in quella mattina
parte molto presto parte da bordo ci sta
portando tutti verso i pirenei francesi
e poi con i nostri piedi andremo verso
la spagna
riconosco subito chi è come me
pellegrini abbiamo uno zaino sopra le
spalle allacciato in vita con delle
cinghie
sopra neanche fosse un albero di natale
qualsiasi cosa calzini mutande pazze il
pranzo
bene
ci distinguono tante lingue eppure negli
occhi abbiamo un'unica meta a santiago
de compostela
quella mattina la mattina della mia
partenza la sveglia suona molto presto
alle 6 e 30 attorno a me pellegrini
stanno già arrotolando i sacchi a pelo
stanno mettendo nello zaino tutto ciò
che è essenziale che cosa essenziale
facile un pantalone uno addosso uno di
ricambio 3 calzini 3 mutande tre
magliette una felpa un poncho per
ripararsi dalla pioggia
una luce per rendere le luci delle
tenebre prima dell'alba e un coltellino
per tagliare pane e formaggio bene il
cammino ci insegna anche a lasciare
tutto ciò che non è essenziale
c'è una tradizione molto importante sul
cammino di santiago che è viene
tramandata di persona in persona
i pellegrini si portano una pietra
questa pietra il simbolo del peso
sapete quando portate sulle spalle dieci
chili per
lungo tempo per circa otto ore
preferireste sicuramente una bottiglia
d'acqua rispetto a un paio di scarpe che
non usate mai
quella pietra il simbolo quindi del peso
io avevo un peso molto importante che
stavo imparando a lasciare per strada in
800 chilometri che ho fatto chiesto a
più di 100 pellegrini perché fa il
cammino
bene la maggior parte di loro mi hanno
risposto
che avevano un peso e quel peso lo
volevano lasciare per strada
il peso appunto non è però solo quello
fisico e soprattutto quello emotivo
il mio peso il peso del controllo altrui
le vittime di violenza hanno nello zaino
principalmente tre cose il controllo
prima mentale poi di come di oresti poi
dei soldi poi dei fino anche dei sogni
che fai lui controlla tutto
ricordo molto bene una frase che mi fu
detta quand'è che ti cambi l'armadio si
troppo magra per cui vestiti
ignorando completamente che avesse
smesso di mangiare proprio a causa sua
ma
la seconda cosa che mettiamo nello zaino
e la manipolazione
vivevo in un costante stato di
disorientamento
i pensieri che stavo facendo erano i
miei o quelli di qualcun altro
le decisioni che stavo prendendo erano
le mie erano indotte
dubitavo fino anche del fatto che stessi
vivendo la vita che volessi veramente
vivere
più tardi nel mio percorso di
psicoterapia
ho capito che quel fenomeno aveva un
nome si chiama vacas lighting ed è
quella manipolazione costante che viene
fatta alle vittime per iniziare a farle
dubitare finanche della loro stessa
percezione
tutto è minacciata
ma il cammino mi stava insegnando che
non era così
e più tardi mi avrebbe insegnato e mi
avrebbe donato un regalo ancora più
grande la fede nell'altro
la terza cosa che si mette nello zaino e
l'isolamento non vi aspettate frase del
tipo non devi vedere più le tue amiche
non considerare più i tuoi genitori
no la manipolazione o molto più sottile
si iniziano a dire frasi del tipo ma sei
sicura che le tue amiche ti capiscono
veramente sei sicura che ti vogliono
bene come ti voglio bene io
inizia a dubitare aree a quel punto e le
tue relazioni sociali si sciolgono come
neve al sole lui diventa il tuo unico
punto di riferimento e tu sei sempre più
sola
niente nel cammino e isolamento tutto e
comunione e condivisione
mangi bevi dormi soffriva e finanche il
bagno con i tuoi amici pelle
il rito è sempre lo stesso arriva in
ostello ti fa la doccia lascia lo zaino
prendi due bottiglie di vino e ti siedi
a tavola la e ti dici bene come ti
chiami da dove vieni perché fa il
cammino
e si creano in quel momento relazioni
che durano per tutta la vita
il cammino t'insegna i veri valori
dell'esistenza non c'è stata una volta
in cui io abbia appoggiato lo zaino e
qualcuno non si sia fermato davanti a me
dicendo hai bisogno di aiuto
quand'è l'ultima volta che vi siete
sentiti dire hai bisogno di aiuto
bene nel cammino e così per uscire dal
teatro della violenza ci vogliono
principalmente tre atti
il primo è la consapevolezza ho toccato
il punto più basso di questo spettacolo
nel momento in cui ho semplicemente
deciso di smettere di mangiare
pesavo 57 chili per un metro e settanta
di un piatto mi bastavano due
forchettate la mia famiglia ovviamente
non poteva che rimanere in silenzio
completamente attonita
da lì c'erano due strade la prima ma era
una lasciarmi andare nel buio la seconda
era chiedere aiuto
il secondo atto è il giudizio non c'è
giudice peggiore di noi stessi
vi starete chiedendo e me lo sono
chiesto anch'io come hai fatto a finire
in questo girone dell'inferno proprio tu
che hai una laurea che hai un master che
stai facendo un mba come è fatto
la verità è che nessuno è immune alla
violenza
dovremmo probabilmente solo togliere il
giudizio è considerare questo come una
tappa del cammino
il terzo atto è quello più bello il
perdono
john mi ha insegnato il perdono
ero a 300 km da santiago
avevo appena fatto 15 chilometri della
giornata mi siedo a un tavolino e vedo
tra figure che vengo mi vengono incontro
la prima è un omone grande e si chiama
john gli occhi tristi le parole sulle
ansiose
accanto a lui c'è mary una donna
asiatica che sterilizza qualsiasi cosa
che trovano
e poi un uomo caduto dai capelli bianchi
con un grande crocifisso al collo
più tardi mi hanno raccontato la storia
che stavano portando in giro per il
cammino di santiago
john aveva dentro dice un bambino
vittima di pedofilia a sei anni era
stato violentato da un prete
john però arrivato a 50 anni aveva
deciso che non voleva più per quella
ferita continuasse a sanguinare e quindi
ha iniziato un suo cammino di
riconciliazione
sapete con chi gli con un prete con il
simbolo del suo dolore padre alvaro
padre alvaro aveva fatto 14 volte il
cammino di santiago ha 81 anni aveva
deciso di fare per l'ultima volta il
cammino proprio con john
john però aveva un ultima cosa da fare
doveva andare dal papa a ricevere il
dono del perdono
john mi ha insegnato davvero che cosa
significava perdonare il più grande
torto che potete fare a una vittima di
violenza e intrappolarla in una gabbia
di dolore e di sfiducia nell'altro john
non stava perdonando solamente il prete
stava principalmente perdonando se
stesso per essere vittima di una colpa
che non aveva voluto
il cammino mi stava facendo un ultimo
donano la fede nell'altro
ero a 60 chilometri da santiago due
giorni alla meta quel giorno ero in
galizia
una terra piena di boschi e di pioggia
ero completamente fradici vedo un bar
entro dentro ordina un caffè mi vado
cambiare poi tornò faccio per pagare il
portafoglio non c'è
abbiamo perso tutto soldi documenti la
possibilità di arrivare in tempo a
santiago la possibilità di tornare in
italia
mi guardo attorno incrocia lo sguardo di
sam un pellegrino che aveva fatto le
ultime cinque tappe con me
lui capisce subito che c'è qualcosa che
non va io gli dico simon perso il
portafoglio lui mi fa cadere lo zaino e
mi dice torno indietro vado a cercare
nel frattempo attorno a man la famiglia
dei pellegrini si raccoglie
c'è un signore spagnolo in particolare
che mi dice chiama la guardia civil
anzi faccio io ho lo spagnolo più fluido
in tre minuti la guardia civil ha
davanti a man e inizia a chiedermi
siamo immediatamente la tua famiglia
lo puoi fare
devono chiamare la farnesina devono far
dare un documento sostitutivo
altrimenti gli ostelli non ti accettano
e tu non puoi tornare in italia
a quel punto
due domande fruscio fondamentali
mi chiesero se l'isola ai soldi sì sì
ero sola e non avevo niente
nel frattempo in quel momento preciso
nelle mie mani
comparse lo 50 euro 20 euro due
pellegrini mi guardarono e mi dissero no
stai tranquilla puoi mangiare e dormire
per due giorni
mentre sempre tornava indietro
c'era un'altra staffetta che stava pur
partendo al contrario tre spagnoli che
avevano dormito con me
quella sera continuavano a ripetere
incessantemente
conoscete la italiana conoscete la
italiana sì c'era qualcuno che conosceva
la italiana era patricia che aveva
dormito con me quella quella sera
lei dice sì sì la conosco io la italiana
di tele che abbiamo trovato il suo
portafogli
a quel punto
la vedo arrivare patrick agita le
braccia e dice l'hanno trovato l'hanno
trovato
a quel punto è facile scoppiare a
piangere
però attorno a me tutto il bar
scoppiava in un applauso fragoroso
il pellegrino sport spagnolo viene verso
di me e mi regala un fiore ore e mi dice
va tutto bene pellegrina e ora di
tornare a camminare
quella pietra quella pietra che ogni
pellegrino si porta dietro viene
lasciata nel punto più alto del cammino
di santiago
la cruz de hierro a 1.500 metri di
altezza
io l'ho vista completamente ricoperta
dalla nebbia come se qualcuno mi stesse
dicendo è l'ultima volta che ti senti
così
bene io in quella pietra ho lasciato
tante cose ho lasciato la paura ora ho
lasciato quella voce che continua a
ripetere non ce la fai
non sei abbastanza
lasciato il giudizio però ho riempito lo
zaino pieno di bellezza colori ori amore
verso me stessa
bene
a quelle persone a quelle donne e uomini
che in questo momento hanno quella
pietra ancora in mano io dico ultreya
avanti con coraggio e ora di cominciare
a camminare a buoncammino
[Applauso]